[Music]
i'm alina and i'm sarah that was weird
and i'm sarah
and i'm sarah and we are holla hub today
we're going to show you how to make a
vegan holla holla halahub is a los
angeles-based delivery company we
deliver holla every friday everyone
loves it vegan or not
what is holla
holla is braided bread traditionally
eaten on the shabbat table for jewish
people everywhere it's the thing that
people gather around every shabbat
shabbat is every friday it's meant to be
a time of rest and connection
[Music]
can we just keep it guys baking baking
is real this is real this is what
happens in life after we had already
started kalahab about six months in
maybe less than that i decided to go
vegan there wasn't any vegan haul
options out there and there's a lot of
vegans out there and alina amazingly was
like okay if we can find a delicious
vegan holla recipe so we tested and
tested and came up with a really amazing
vegan recipe that we're super proud of
the thing that's interesting is it's a
religious bread right it's associated
with judaism but a lot of our followers
on instagram and a lot of our customers
are not jewish and they don't have to be
if the thing at the center of your
shabbat table is our bread then we just
think that's the coolest thing ever
really like elena and i's friendship has
not existed without hala the first time
we met it was when i was at a brunch
showing pictures of khao that i had
baked and alina was like i'll buy you
brunch if we make hollow together and i
was like deal i love a free brunch i've
been doing so much research and looking
up so many videos on youtube i never
baked chala before i met sarah for me
was kind of like a ketchup when it comes
to braiding yeah the student has to pass
the teacher i cannot do a sixth strand
nearly as nice as she can
sarah has the patience to create amazing
sculptures with holla i have no patience
for it the joke is that i do all of that
stuff and alina make sure everything
actually gets done the business stays a
business so there's a lot of crossover
with what we both do but when it comes
down to it the stuff that i really don't
want to do she is really happy doing and
is really good at doing and vice versa
we're going to make a four strand round
hollow your tic-tac-toe set up and then
you're just gonna weave all the way
around every other strand over and then
you go back the other direction yeah and
if anything looks weird you can just
tuck it right under and no one will know
really that's what bread making is all
about hiding the wonky parts we're
really different we every time we go and
do classes people are like what's the
right way to do this and depending on
which one of us you ask you'll get a
different answer it's true mine's the
right one so
next we're gonna do a rainbow six strand
challah for braiding when you're laying
out your strands each position is how
you count like what strand number it is
if we make colored dough we love using
all the natural dyes that are out there
like matcha spirulina dragon fruit
powder blueberry powder there's so much
out there and don't stress if it's not
perfect that's the other thing a lot of
people are like oh god the brain looks
so hard and crazy and no this one is
going to be difficult sometimes when you
try to connect the different colors to
each other you might have a difficult
time but we promise that once you bake
it it will look great and no one's going
to complain you're making rainbow bread
but when it comes to like actually
making haul at home it's artisan so it
can be uh wonky looking and that's
totally fine we love our wonky holla to
me hala means family and friends
specifically on a friday night and then
for sure french toast i think that's
like the best
don't wrap your chala if it's hot no one
wants that it's gonna get all soggy take
your hollow out of the oven put it on a
cooling rack let it chill out and then
once it's cool then you can cut into it
rip into it we always have the fight rip
or cut and you can definitely no you rip
it that's disgusting you can't share it
if you're going around and getting tasty
it's fine it's like animals
i can't enjoy hollow when i cut it
really no i think you're lying
[Music]
oh my gosh it's both popping so um can i
just see it for a second sure
wait what oh yes
[Music]
you